what up what up it's the original dom
kennedy and you can check me out right
here on that bullet caf podcast opm
boulet cav show special guests in here
got the homie dom kennedy man that's
right that's right with it oh boo that
cab good to be here
hey so um
talk about man first of all you've been
on a run a very underrated run the last
few years between the half a mil [ __ ]
you put out last year and then
from the west side would love three yeah
this is like your baby this series yeah
it's kind of the
i remember the first time i heard 1997
like
just this is kind of like the
original was what really put you on the
map exactly um
why
now
have dropped part three because part two
was what 2011 2011 first one 2010 2011
2021 um man just the ups and downs of
the music game you know i'm saying
loving it being in love with it you know
having some successes you know being
underrated getting to the label stage
taking meetings you know and just
realizing like
like you said my passion is from the
west i would love you know when one of
my staple
you know
i don't know somebody asked me one day
if you had a book about your life what
would you call it and i was like from
the west i would love you know what i'm
saying
and um
so as i'm you know after working with
here boy let's say maybe 2018
2017 2019 last year i put out wrap and
roll you know i kind of kept the songs
that i do a hit separate from songs that
i create on my own with other producers
and then we started working and i did a
couple solo songs and i told him like
man you know he was really inspiring me
in like a different way with my music
and i told him like you know what i
think i can make from the west side with
love three you know and i need your help
you know and that was kind of the
beginning of it and that was like a year
and a half ago you know it's crazy the
just the relationship that you guys
musically have put on paper the last few
years yeah whether it's the half a mil
[ __ ] or whether it's
like i feel like
hearing you on records with like nahs
like just certain [ __ ] that like you
never thought you would ever hear and i
feel like what what like like
one day we'll look back at like
the last few years that hit boys had and
just the magic that's coming out of his
studio the relationships that are
happening hey man um
you know the [ __ ] he's doing with sean
that she's doing with knowledge she's
doing with you
and i i just think it's real special
like what's that energy like over there
because anytime you go over to hit spot
like
you'll never know who's going to be in
the studio never know and he's bringing
so many worlds together that wouldn't be
together yeah never know bring so many
from you know producers to engineers
like the engineer i work with now it
built the relationship through working
with head you know and um
several artists even collabs that's
never come out or you know we never done
any music you know people like anderson
pack you know i mean like people like
sweetie you know i mean like they'll
literally be in the studio on a random
day you know i'm saying in the
collaborations is open so when you hear
me with like quinn miller or like knives
for instance on the courtesy of half a
meal those is just coming from everybody
just building me on big sean album you
know that that's coming from us
eating together sharing music sharing
ideas somebody playing sean maybe
playing a verse and it may be like i
could try i could add something to that
you know and it ended up on his album
you know what i'm saying but that's all
directly related around here boy like
he's like the sun you know i mean the
solar system and we are our planets but
we are moving around
brawl's energy and his spirit you are in
burden of proof too right i was yeah
exactly and that's like something that
nobody like i would never ever think
that
benny would be on a record i never had
no relationship with nobody shout out to
benny the butcher miss obviously super
talented you know east coast cmc but
it's no connection there outside of here
boy you know that's
oh what hit i'm doing the album with
benny he he's
six seven songs in that's what's up i'm
listening to it like damn bro hard you
know he coming in every day working
listening to beats just see his process
was different so in the instance of that
song that i'm on you know just seeing
how he took his time just mentally
writing he didn't write nothing down but
he was just walk around listening to the
song and then i'm like again like yo i
could contribute
that's a big factor for me that's one
thing that me and her always talk about
it's like whether it's a dom kennedy
song or not i always got something i
could contribute even if it's just
insight even if it's four bars a bars
whatever i always have something to
contribute and just being in that
environment and people knowing who i am
i think as well obviously you know
allows me to them to be like yeah go
ahead you know what i mean and then like
in the case of that benny song just
dropping that hook and then being like
damn [ __ ] hard you know what i mean and
then next thing i know it's out and
people are like i heard you on benny a
butcher album
yeah that's what's up you know what i
mean you talked about being like
underappreciated
underrated yeah i feel like your whole
career that's kind of been the story
right you said that i didn't say that no
you just didn't you just say that i
don't know you said i said that yeah you
said that all right um
but what is the uh like for you yeah i
feel like you kind of been the people's
champ at la for for your whole career
you know what i'm saying and and and you
have like
a extremely hardcore fan base that just
[ __ ] with you and they [ __ ] with you
over all this time like we think
it's been 11 years since the first from
west side would love yeah put my first
project out in 20 2008 man so i've been
in it for a minute yeah man for sure 13
plus at least you know what do you think
is like um
you know the reason why maybe you might
still be a little underrated or why you
still kind of fly under the commercial
radar a bit well i never embrace fully
commercial success
you know never chase like fully
commercial um
approval i don't want to say records
because to me a song is just a song
right i'm saying there's certain things
that you have to do obviously if you
want
you know maximum spins and exposure and
to fit into you know what they call now
playlist but just fully never embracing
you know one of my homies that really
know me he he told me a couple years ago
like man he felt like i kind of did
everything but like
embrace the rap game
you feel like you're in the rap game but
you're kind of like an outsider right
exactly and you're like at peace with
that i'm sure yeah for sure um but yeah
and and that just him saying that kind
of made it more more like put it on my
conscience more to like
i don't want to be a anti
a you know the rap game so it's not like
i'll go out my way to embrace it or do
things even like the features that we
just was talking about and things like
that but that's probably things four or
five years ago i probably wouldn't even
i was gonna say oh dom like i felt like
like seeing you on all these albums just
wouldn't have been available right you
know for stuff like that but just
understanding my position in it and how
important it is to myself and others
like and once my real you know somebody
that really love you and know you you
know pre the rap game and all that
really tells you something like that you
gotta listen you know and so i did i did
take it to heart and i began like you
know just examining everything just
helping more people and and myself even
you know where i could yeah no i think
like um you obviously
as far as like
you had other opportunities too right
because i know
there was a point in time where everyone
was trying to sign you yeah um at the
peak of mmg i know you guys had
conversations like yeah what was like
were you always just like yo i'm gonna
do with the opm way like i'm you know
like like why did why did you never
really take that bigger step as far as
like
um never ownership was never on the
table
and i always more than anything more
than being a celebrity more than being
super rich off for you know whatever
they could offer me right in any way i
always wanted to be a ceo
you know what i'm saying like i always
wanted to be a ceo i always thought of
myself as a ceo and i always felt like i
was smarter than just what the
microphone and the instrumental
had to offer you know and i and i and my
only thing was it wasn't a fear i had
but i never wanted to just be diminished
like as good as i could be as a rapper
as an artist i never just wanted to just
be that
you know that would have felt like a
failure to me automatically like if you
try if i had a room full of plaques and
like a pile full of money like no need
like uh duck tales right right right and
i was just a rapper i would still feel
bad because you're not fulfilled because
i was yeah it was exactly i would just
be disposable you know artists based off
of whatever song i was people deemed was
tight high at the time and that would be
you know and i would be just chasing
that well how how serious were those
talks because i remember ross had talked
to you and nip at that time and whiz at
that time yeah um how serious do those
talks get um well where mmg that was
more like uh um obviously i was a lot
younger than i was still in man was a
big fan of rick ross you know what i
mean and so that out that was more
predicated on
you know somebody that was heavy in the
game and still is and somebody like
myself who was up and coming who hoped
to be you know get good at this [ __ ] get
great at this and just trying to learn
you know like
from them um i had other situations with
major labels that was a lot closer to
being
a real you know situation but again when
it came down to ownership and to opm
being represented the right way in the
deal
it never really sat right with me they
never really saw the full full potential
of like what it what it was that i
wanted to do and what we was capable of
doing so again it was easy for me to say
no because if all i was gonna be
diminished to was like an artist on
trial
i had passed that all the artists that
they was trying to do that way i had did
more shows than them already
you know i'm saying like i had sold more
t-shirts than them already you know like
we was doing venues like i wasn't
interested in none of that you know i
was not genuinely in my heart i was
never really interested in any of that
what would be some advice you would give
to like a bubbling artist because
obviously you came up in a different era
when
i mean i really feel like it was kind of
like peak blog era yeah too dope boy
it's not right you know when i was
starting out and and we was first
getting noticed yep yeah it was coming
out of that it's definitely free music
yeah it was a different time and i also
thought it was dope because there were
so many curators that really had power
yeah because like maybe
shake and mech [ __ ] with you over here
yeah so if they post you like rap radar
might you know what i mean it was now
it's like
very few people in charge of these
playlists right that can make or break
people's careers but at the same time
like there's other ways to build a
organic following and to monetize being
an artist if you could figure out how to
get those fans to you know spend money
with you but in 2021 what would be some
advice you would give to some upcoming
artists that are kind of bubbling mm-hmm
like just to kind of you know whether or
not it's to stay independent or to sign
or just some things man now it's a
different game you know it would depend
on what you what your intent was coming
in you know my intent was to build a
label i was inspired by jay prince
master p suge knight sean combs russell
simmons people like that that was the
type of legacy regardless of if anybody
wanted to box me in as just you know in
a blogger rapper that's how i honestly
saw myself and my label you know and i
and i'm still working towards that right
now
so if you're artist coming in right now
you might need a label to push a record
because like you said it's so many
gatekeepers now and the game is so in
the twist
i can't like i don't see too many people
that could do what i do that's just
being honest that's just being honest
you know what i mean like i'm not going
to sugarcoat it like i never did back
then and i don't especially right now
because to do what i do you have to be
really great you have to have a lot of
you know that's why i only really [ __ ]
with nip coming up right because he the
only one that had the courage in the you
know i'm saying the talent and to back
it up you know and to go out there like
i was talking before is you got to go
out in your hometown and do your thing
and around the country as well around
the world as well and represent you know
what i'm saying and let people see that
and it's like if you can't do that if
you're not willing to do that without no
machine behind you you can't play in my
game
you can't play it's impossible it's
impossible you know what i mean i did it
couple times you know multiple times
um and it's like i i would not lie to
somebody and tell them like follow my
footsteps
to walk down that same path no not at
all you know a lot of them they need the
system
yeah because if you don't got the system
behind you then you got to really depend
on yourself you got to be willing to
take risks exactly you got to have money
you got to have insight you got to be
able to you know weather through a whole
couple seasons maybe you're just
grinding it out with great producers you
know me
me and nip in the studio with mike and
kids for eight months
them days is over you know what i'm
saying like we had great producers we
had great ideas but that led us to the
victories into the better days later but
it's like
a lot of people they can't they can't
weather that they want instant results
you know i mean it took us years of
believing in ourselves
and working on what we thought was good
to be able to present it to the world
you know i don't see that type of
patience right right people yeah the
patience is kind of out the window these
days yeah people want instant results
yeah they want to put out a song and you
know instant gratification yeah go viral
and do their thing and that's all good
but that that type of response takes
like a a system without it yeah no that
kind of response takes a bag exactly
yeah it takes like a machine it does and
i wouldn't lie to a kid and tell them
like oh you could do this or you could
achieve these type of numbers or these
type of results without that because
otherwise you're hitting the lottery if
you because it happens but it happens
very
seldomly right like some somebody
independently gets a tick tock record
that goes great you know what i'm saying
that it's like hitting the lotto right
yeah um you mentioned like how you
obviously you and nip's relationship was
uh you know a great one one that was
very important to hip hop um
you guys put out incredible records
together you guys were peers for
i feel like you guys kind of
career-wise were parallel to each other
the whole time um what was it about nip
from the jump that you guys just kind of
saw each other as this you know like
he's one of me you know what i'm saying
like um he built the same way just the
neighborhood you know i'm saying where
nip comes from i know that area well you
know the myrrh park is down the street
you know this is all actual factuals not
just rap you know and uh we got a lot of
the same homies and knew a lot of the
same people coming up i didn't know nip
growing up but immediately when i saw
him
you know doing what he was
gonna do in the music business i
understood it because i had that type of
heart as well you know i had that type
of heart as well and i knew that
immediately upon discovering him that um
this was somebody that i was gonna work
with and you know our
our um
our careers would be intertwined in a
way you know and i chose and i chose to
make it a good story you know
immediately even before i met him you
know um and so you know just meeting him
i thought like you know he was brilliant
he was serious about what he was going
to do i could tell that at a young age
and i and the most important thing i
love was the structure of the business i
love you know
black sam you know
you know household names j-rock you know
fats rest in peace you know these was
like kyby supreme these was like people
that he really loved and worked with and
they all respected each other and i
thought that
i wanted my friends and my family to see
that because that's what i wanted you
know i wanted us to be and eventually we
had separate crews he had all money in i
have opm
but you know when we got together it was
always like a family thing you know we
had shows together where
you know his family will be selling
merch my family will be selling merch
simple as that you know trading secrets
side by side on you know new
technologies and things like that things
that people never really saw right you
know and that was like those were the
most important things to me you know
what i mean to be there for him when um
he was trying to make something of his
career when people maybe didn't believe
in it but i knew how talented and how
special that he was
for sure it's just you ha it's an art
tool to this all you know and trying to
get people to feel that through music is
not easy you know no it's definitely i
feel like you guys are always going to
be synonymous with each other
in terms of just the classic record
y'all got yeah for sure and i just feel
like
you know out of la
from like 2010 on like you guys were
built for the longevity like if you
think about all the artists that came up
during that area obviously it was
kendrick j rock but yeah but you guys
kind of i feel like
you guys kind of embody ownership yeah
[ __ ] accountability yeah for sure
accountability we used to talk about it
a lot you know it was worse that was
thrown around you know and
the great thing about it is now we we
inspired a lot of
artists that's out right now doing their
thing and just that's the most
incredible part is that all those times
that we were sitting around trying to
make songs and inspire people and you
know find our fans and our voices and
it's like now people really appreciate
it you know and we probably didn't get
that then and we wasn't in it for the
glory or the credit immediately so it
didn't really matter but i think the
beautiful thing is like all the artists
that's out right now that's having their
career having a way with it was the ones
that was inspired and listening to the
things that we was putting out you know
when we was doing our thing um
there was like this uh
i know that there was supposed to be
like some sort of super group with you
nip and was it yg
a little bit yeah yeah yeah you know
about that
okay so like this like nipsy yg dom yeah
i remember like like hearing that this
was like a real thing that was supposed
to happen yeah it was talks about it um
what what ended up happening with that
and like how far along did those talks
get like um i remember we had a couple
phone conversations about it like
everybody had to get on the phone
you know a couple people i think they
just was surprised at that time and
wanted to
hear everybody's voice together to agree
with it because it was like speculation
i don't even know who first presented or
came up with it but yeah it was it was a
little time where that was like on the
table and i remember we had a maybe one
or two phone calls a body where we were
all on a conference call just in
agreement with it and just you know
just didn't end up working out nah i
mean i think that
all those careers was just going in
different trajectories at that time and
that was one of the things because we
never even really got in and made no
songs or like made no plans it was just
all like talks as i was gonna say was
like so there was no music that was
recorded
damn no it was no like official sessions
for that at all in any way
um
do you do you still have unreleased
records with nip that are that may or
may not see the light of day one day um
me personally i don't not that i could
think of no every single thing that i'm
i'm saying i'm sure that there are
songs that you know either myself mike
and keys they got autumn music you know
some [ __ ]
yeah so i'm not saying that people won't
but it's nothing that i have that i'm
like oh i'm saving this for this you
know or like i have it for this or nip
did a verse or drop like no i don't have
anything like that uh double up is
obviously one of the highlights of
victory lap
what can you tell us about
your
your role in that record and how that
record came came out man that was a
beautiful evening man um
nip had you know he was working on his
album we went from like you know on the
come up and in the times where we was
really working together we worked
together heavy like damn near every day
for like a couple years all the time you
know and then
um when i got the deal with atlantic and
i was doing other stuff i had traveled
and did a couple tours
and i hadn't really seen it as much for
like a little window besides like shows
he came to one of my festivals in
anaheim
um might have been day and night i don't
know at the angel stadium
that was a big one yeah he came out and
showed up for me um
and then a little bit after that you
know he was working on the album the
whole time though that's one thing i
could say like he took his time with it
always focus like about that album and
being adamant about it coming out one
day how it was because i remember having
combos with him
years ago and him playing me songs that
was still on our ideas that were you
know way before
that album came out so
you know in the midst of all of that you
know i would see bro and um he was like
man come
i got i want to play the album he was he
was camped out at uh
what's the spot on vine you know it uh
paramount he used to have his whip right
there and pear on the curb everybody
know that knowing
i went up there one day and he was like
yeah you know the music i'm just vibing
just listening showing my support he was
getting tatted it was funny because i
remember he was getting blasted
the big arm money in on that was a part
of the rollout he took his shirt off a
lot on the campaign so i was there
tonight he was getting blasted and he
was playing me songs
and um he was like man really i just got
one verse song that i really really love
that i haven't
did two verses but that could make the
album man he played it and i just went
right in the booth and i remember he was
getting tired he was smiling just
looking at me you know i mean recording
i'll never forget that and i could just
see him through the window and he was
like listening to what i was saying and
he was getting tatted
and um it was just a cool night man and
the next time i really heard the song i
really found out you know how it went
down was really when they were released
on it being at the release party yeah
exactly and then hearing you know
exactly what belly had added to it and
just the final project man and i just
thought it was like the highest quality
you know not that that's not that's what
i expect from nick but i was really
floored by how well you know he was able
to weather the storm and really get his
vision all the way out on the highest
level man i'll forever be proud of him
for that yes
it might be my favorite song of victory
lap it's one of them but it's it's crazy
because like i just think like what if
nip was still here and he was over there
at chalice with
what's going on at hit boy spot like i'm
like rocks in the middle that's what i'm
saying like they just were getting they
were just getting their their their like
you know what i'm saying like just
imagine
the crazy collabs
i know i think about it every day man
that was the last place i saw him and
spoke to him at
in hit boy um studio
finishing rocks in the middle yep you
know it's crazy man yeah r.i.p um
they're great hey what up man we got to
interrupt the interview real quick to
tell you about our family at odd socks
now when i be riding for odd socks so
hard man it's because i really love the
product they got the most comfortable
socks in the [ __ ] world i got a pair
of odd socks basics on right now go get
those they got the socks wwe joints you
know i'm saying shout out to the
undertaker pepsi [ __ ] really
whatever you need some weed socks
nickelodeon but really they got the
draws now ladies and gentlemen
i'm holding a pair of tapatio underwear
right now
you want some pop tarts on your dick pop
tart draws and these [ __ ] are
so comfortable like
man so listen you gotta go to
oddssoxofficial.com
and use the uh promo code the discount
code bootleg kev
at oddssocksofficial.com you'll save 20
off underwear the most comfortable socks
in the world crazy licenses not only
they got the wwe they got the scarface
they got the street fighter they got the
nickelodeon they got it all so make sure
you hit that website oddsoxofficial.com
save 20 off with the promo code bootleg
kev all right go do that shout out to
odd socks let's get back to the
interview you got to help me understand
man
when or how
can we get
the original
on the dsps and the yellow album on the
test keys
okay those those are real expensive i
say that a lot my fans know because of
all the features in the sample clearance
no disrespect to that piff and they're
right and they're added off man they
have nothing to do with it no but i'm
just saying that if i want to listen to
i gotta go down there i know or i gotta
pull up to youtube recently i just
almost been like you know [ __ ] it and
let's just take our shot and just run it
see what happens you can't see what
happens
i know we'll get so
so listen static selected always told me
this because he samples every all his
[ __ ] right i don't really want to air
his [ __ ] out like
but he's like hey bro [ __ ]
if if i get sued that means the record's
doing something yep facts
facts man but with the again with the
guest features on there with the
paperwork that they tied to you could
imagine that they're not going to let
that feature [ __ ] might be tough i got
rig ross unless you just throw it out
without it without it having any of the
features on it like like the track list
is just it doesn't say their name on it
oh yeah i would have to
i would have to if i went that way but i
have been in discussions um we working
on some maybe a little anniversary or
just some fly like a relaunch for that
one that would be special man i
definitely want to do that before um
sooner than later i will say that i
think about it a lot i've been in
discussions with
you know people that don't even have
nothing to do with me honestly but just
i just want to help that's in tune with
business and music and they're like yo
you know
look into this this and this but it's a
process you know it's like whiz finally
got cushioned orange juice on the day
exactly and then exactly
you know exactly big crit got all his
old [ __ ] on the dsps it takes time joey
badass yeah and the era like you guys
came up like they were mixtapes but they
weren't they were problems that was free
music it was just free music it was
great music for me i always made wanted
to make my music
as albums i always try to keep that
integrity but it was free music back
then you know so i don't feel cheated i
don't feel you know better about none of
that because then that's how i made that
music you know i knew what i was doing
going into i came off the
era where they thought the music
business was done
that's real you feel what i'm saying
like people forget that when they ask
questions and they think like oh
they spotted like [ __ ] i don't think
about spotify when i make songs i'm
sorry you know what i'm saying like i
i'm i'm pat i was around before that
like i think about the fans i think
about what i want to say i think about
great music yeah because back then you
guys had to figure out how to monetize
everything else what the music because
you were driving you should die tomorrow
i would not give a [ __ ] you feel me like
i would still do my thing i would still
figure it out i would still make a way
just like i did before that's all they
result of trying to be in the music
business like that it doesn't really
affect like my process you know but at
the end of the day i want to get the
flyers music possible to the fans so
that's where we have where i have to
deal with it you know yeah it's it's
it's definitely uh
i feel like with a lot of like my
favorite artists from that era it's like
[ __ ] like j cole i just saw him at the
forum and he performed some [ __ ] on
friday night live so i'm like only if we
could get friday night lights on
it's not yes
but yeah i imagine it's a lot of artists
and a lot of great you know music like
back in the day you know old school
walleye tapes like all that [ __ ] like
yeah you want to buy a certain movie on
dvds but it might not be at best buy
that's real you feel what i'm saying
like that's that's how the game goes
sometimes i was looking for the mac you
know what i mean on dvd i'll be trying
to find [ __ ]
can i buy it on amazon prime exactly i'm
like [ __ ]
hard to find you know um
as far as the ceo [ __ ] man like
obviously you know you've been building
uh opm for a minute yeah you know you
got some really dope talented artists
that you've been working with over the
years shout out to nico 4g g4
nico g4 i remember he came in freestyle
killed it with you but um what is like
the roster looking like now um we man we
bout to expand 2022 we're expanding
right now we still got dom kennedy of
course we got j305 nico shout out to jay
who's one of our the funniest
[ __ ] alive yeah exactly man
that's my homie you know what i'm saying
um
it's a small roster you know i'm saying
right now but i'm expanding man i don't
want to say like what i got going in the
works right now and you know put it all
the way out there but definitely in 2022
you're gonna see some new artists come
out on opm you know what i mean and the
whole vision is gonna come to fruition
for sure so looking forward to distro
like interscope was kind of your partner
on on on some [ __ ] right no that wasn't
or
they was trying to sign us but that's
what it was yeah they was trying to do a
deal with us but mainly just with me you
know and j305 ended up at a point he had
a solo deal that's what i was thinking
yeah he had a solo deal for his uh first
album came out officially through
interscope but no dom kennedy music
nothing else ever came what's the latest
what's going on with jay
he's about to put out some singles
hopefully sooner than later probably top
of the year you know what i'm saying but
he's working on some singles right now
playing me a couple you know songs but
jsj he gonna do what he do you know what
i'm saying he official like so it's hard
for him to kind of like
be he's a l.a celebrity and then it's
the rap game right i'm saying yeah not
for sure yeah like celebrity kind of
always takes
precedent over the rap game you know
i mean we we all got friends here in the
l.a hip-hop scene that are the same way
exactly
exactly
you talked about being influential to a
lot of the artists that are kind of
doing their thing now yeah um someone
who i always kind of when i listen to i
always reminds me of you is larry june
haha like johnny here i feel like larry
june's like the like based dom kennedy
yeah yeah for sure larry john man i look
at him as the baddies larry jones man
but he's been killing it for years yeah
i'm glad to see he he keeps someone
who's finally starting to get a lot of
like looks but like well deserved um
who are some people who you like that
that
you're fans of that is a part of the new
generation of the rapture that you're
like glass
blast
um don toliver
you know i really like his innovation
you know what i'm saying um
[ __ ]
people like meg the stallion you know
and jason cash she another artist that's
crazy
yeah from carson exactly chopping it
with him you know and be no riddle
obviously you know i was just at b no
show last night you know and all of
those people is kind of like loosely
intertwined and you know
music that i had probably a decade ago
that helped them kind of see themselves
in the space that they ain't right now
you know i'm saying it and it's like
that's important for me but those people
right there kind of stick out the most
you know meeting somebody like blast and
them truly like knowing about my catalog
and like what year certain [ __ ] came out
and where they was at with it and then
seeing the success they have
you know it definitely makes me feel
good because it's like all that work
didn't go unnoticed all that music you
know we i'm real sincere about this [ __ ]
you know making music being an artist
first and foremost and so when you see
other artists flourishing
and doing anything and they just
randomly might shout you out a lot of
people was hitting me like a year ago
and don tyler was doing his press run
and he was shouting me out a lot on on
like bigger platforms and people was
kind of like thrown off by it but you
know i understood it because i've done
shows for years in houston right right
you know for years in houston no
coverage no big you know hoopla but
selling out shows and i'm like these are
the type of people reason why i was out
there selling tickets and having fans it
was kids like that that was probably in
high school doing their thing whatever
and they was
for some reason they gravitated towards
my message and my music you know nah
that's crazy yeah there's definitely
like a i feel like
you're you know
phoenix is where i'm from and i know
that's a big market for you but yeah you
have like your certain pockets of the
country where [ __ ] just show
out for you
yeah arizona dc
you know
for you what that's great hell yeah yeah
hell yeah shout out to dc maryland
virginia period but like my show in d.c
i like howard theater
silver springs maryland
cracking crazy cracking yeah for sure
for years though
years like this is not new you know this
like years supported me for years you
know atlanta
detroit you know for real these is
places that's like filled with real
people that really you know on a random
day during the week you know in bad
weather you know we'll come out and pack
a venue for me just to see me you know
do my thing and i definitely appreciate
it um
you also always have like a a banger on
deck with t fly yeah t fly someone who
um i think
maybe doesn't get enough flowers like
you know i had
the the uh this dick record that was
huge yeah um but like you guys always
have have a record together yeah i feel
like it almost feels like every project
fly is like my brother man like he it
was funny because okay in that era where
i was talking about about working with
nipping doing all that i met t fly
during those times he had the studio in
the same building next to us okay but i
didn't know t fly but every day all he
used to sleep at the studio we would
leave like we kind of was having money a
little bit you know we had cars see fly
was on the come up about to get a deal
with i think
sony epic whoever he had his deal with
right he was trying to get that deal and
but we i was so i was hearing all the
music that he was recording that wasn't
out and that's how i got familiar with
him
so by the time i'm working on get home
safely and i remember i was somewhere at
a truck stop on the road one day and
somebody came up to me and it's a true
story like randomly i swear to god like
two in the morning i'm at a little thing
looking through the little glass about
to get a ginger ale or some [ __ ] of
water and the dude's like he's staring
at me i'm obviously like okay he gonna
say something about music and he asked
me like how did you know to put t fly on
that song
and i was like damn
i mean i guess that's how he looked at
it you know like it just came out of
nowhere but not when we was recording t
fly was in that same building recording
so i was hearing his songs every day he
was recording three or four songs and i
realized i knew the songs before they
came out oh wow because i was hearing
them playing them all day while we was
just sitting there eating chilling i was
hearing them so by the time i got to
doing get home safely and i had to be
for still calling i asked i sat i went
in this room and i said could you do a
hook for me on this and then i'll do the
verse you know what i'm saying and i sat
there with him and he was like cool and
that's really how our collaborations
really started working you know i'm
saying after that one day it was like a
saturday i remember and i was like man i
got this beat bro i think that you would
kill it and we did still calling that
day and then i've been working with bro
literally ever since till [ __ ] i've seen
them last week yeah you guys i feel like
yeah we never really fell out you know
i'm saying because
you know what i understand what he does
and he understands what i do and we
always rocking and um you know i put out
an ep on opm like a five song ep and i
end up being on four songs not
intentionally but just being on songs
but yeah me and t fly working on some a
collaboration for the people man i'm
glad you had it nice so you guys gonna
put up yeah opm we gonna play the album
oh [ __ ] yeah that's together yeah yeah
we already working on it i was working
on it before that's a bullet kev
exclusive so t fly dom project on the
way yeah i mean i feel like you guys
have such a crazy chemistry yeah we
gonna do a whole album we already we
already more than halfway in i kind of
put it on pause to finish the west side
three but that's how i got that
intermission and it was kind of like a
warm up to introducing to keep the vibes
going for the album people will hear it
but we got a great you know we're gonna
put out a great body of work 2022. how
many records you guys have done
right now [ __ ] maybe 12 but only like
sounds like an album yeah
but yeah probably really like three or
four that i really want to keep we got a
lot of work to do but we're going to put
it out though it's already on the books
for sure
yeah it's already on the books it's
something we've been working on um one
of my favorite records of yours was cdc
with you carter and uh and casey
yeah shout out casey veggies um that
record was incredible and i always just
but we used to bump the [ __ ] out of that
song
did you guys ever talk about putting the
tape out it was like cdc or was there
any sort of like it was just being funny
like abbreviating our names at that time
you know what i'm saying the title that
song that was a beat that hit boy had
through us and we just hit boy beat
that's so crazy i don't even realize
that was her boy and that was casey
veggies just going crazy on it like how
he do pulling up standing you know
staying in attendance bro got off on it
at my studio and then the rest is
history you know but that was a hit boy
beat that came out of a photo of some
beasts that he boy gave me that casey
had picked and just went well here was
that was that 2012 11 11 that was so
that was
that was around the time
watch the throne came out that was
pretty that so it was like right before
that though you could even say a lot
that the
the thesis for watch the throne was that
song
that's crazy yeah you could say that
wholeheartedly you could say that that
sound spun off of that right there
that's wild yo so um the album is out is
there going to be another opm
compilation now i hope so young nation
man thanks for asking yeah that's one
thing i've been flirting with you know
what i mean nico g4 he just put out a
tape called winners tape is doing pretty
well and then just in the midst of like
recording westside with love three
working with jay you know those young
nation compilation albums are designed
for everybody to shine and then to spin
off and get fans on their own solo
projects so it's definitely one like it
was a big gap between the first one and
the second one and one thing i've been
telling the crew is like
we gotta do a better job if that's a
platform that we have we we should do a
better job of introducing new music new
artists stand current ourselves with new
ideas and new production through those
platforms so it's very very likely that
you'll see a
a young nation volume 3 and 2022 as well
do you feel like you're still like
learning rolling with the punches when
it comes to doing the ceo [ __ ] because
there's no like it's no real blueprint
it's nothing right it's not and it
changes every day you know people in
positions that you might meet and have a
contact and then next you might call
them two months later and they'll be
like oh i'm not even doing that no more
but i'm doing this you know what i'm
saying so i've learned that i've learned
how to deal with producers artists you
know i've i've had artists now that have
deals and then god don't have deals and
you know i had a group called warren
brew they was doing their thing they
don't was one brew they did are they the
ones who did you guys collaborated uh
with the red bull was it yeah yeah
exactly they had a i had a situation
where red bull but they're not a group
anymore you know so i kind of have
learned that it's like
being a ceo and being having a true
label is not like everything doesn't go
as planned so hell yeah i'm
it's it's upside down
broke up yeah okay yeah officially you
know that and that that's not an opm
call that's a warm bro like i
collaborate with these people but you
know just going from okay this is
something new this is exciting to like
damn they don't even want they're not
doing it no more you know and you kind
of got to accept that just like a label
does like every artist at a label signs
maybe one out of what a hundred of them
go platinum that's real you know
for them yeah so you can't sit around
and be like
oh they don't you know so this didn't
work out so it's it's done like nah you
just keep going you you take it as a
lesson learned you got great music that
you made in the process and things that
you learn and you just apply that [ __ ]
going forward you know but yeah i take a
lot of it's been more bruises on that
side than anything man being on the ceo
side is tough it and for a point in time
it weighed down on my artistry as well
you know because as i got older as i'm
you know i'm older now so i wanted to
like be more involved in business you
know and i was cool with being an artist
obviously i made dope songs i was a
rapper but it kind of started bothering
me i think in a way a couple years where
it was like i wanted to be more in the
business and more you know serious about
that and help more artists but it just
wasn't working out so it kind of like
you know not sour how i looked at the
game but just like it made it less fun i
will say that yeah i feel like when you
start dealing with other artists
and you start dealing with
individuals in general right with
anything like you feel like yo
i've done all this
is it like hard like i don't use the
word babysitting but is it hard to like
work with a bunch of different variables
when it comes to being like hey
it is this is what you need to do it is
but you can't walk someone it is because
it's non-transferable man it's like i
work out at seven o'clock right
if i go work out
you don't get stronger
you know what i'm saying you to go i
could tell you what i'm doing i could
even let you come you know ride with me
but
i'm gonna be there pull up right yeah if
you don't do the same things at least
like how could you expect the same
results you know and it's
non-transferable so no matter nothing i
tell you or try to pound into your head
could really work unless you embrace it
and do it yourself and your results
might be better than mine you know
that's one thing i try to get them to
understand like
i didn't do it the best way or the right
way i did it my way you know what i
thought was best at the time for me
my my self-esteem my state of mind you
know my heart like i do what's best for
that but that doesn't mean that you got
to do what i do you know and do it your
way you know take the good parts lead
the parts you don't like i think the
best artists that end up making it and
having the most longevity i mean
everyone has management and all that but
are kind of like self-managers if that
makes sense you got to like they almost
like
they're
like if they didn't have management they
would take the initiative their
self-starters yeah you know what i'm
saying you got to you got to um because
i see so many artists that are [ __ ]
incredible but the reason why they never
made it it's maybe because they were
lazy or they just didn't yeah
you got to be self-motivated man
nobody's gonna at the end of the day
your manager you know all of that they
following your lead you know they can
only get you to believe and do and do so
much you know and um another thing is
like people want to see us as the artist
enthusiastic you know we got to love it
before we could sell it to anybody even
your manager even your you know whoever
like people could tell if you really in
tune if you really are who you say you
are if you really are what you pushing
you know and what you want is to
attract people that
believe in the same things as you you
know i'm saying and don't mind you know
spreading promoting whatever it is
you know your agenda your product you
know 100 yeah how are you going to
ask someone to be enthusiastic about
your [ __ ] right you're not and you just
laid up like you know not really
tripping and you want them to be you
know come back like oh i got you on jay
leno and it's like what like that don't
happen you know
they look at it like that but that
that's not how the game goes you know
people some people be too cool about
their own [ __ ] and it's like yo this is
your [ __ ] exactly if you don't love it
you cannot expect anybody else to work
harder than you are to love your product
more than you that's a fool's game and
even even like when you like you know
there's we're in l.a right so there's
always opportunities where people will
get the ox cord in the studio like yo
don't just play that [ __ ] and like sit
back right you got to like feel your
[ __ ] in those moments
and work your way up to feeling that if
you don't feel that way be honest about
it and keep going till you do um are you
when hip boy gonna do any more half a
mil [ __ ] yeah courtesy how familiar i
mean originally it was a trilogy anyway
so we we've dropped two albums we put
out the eps just because we was just
learning how to work and what we was
going to be talking about but we've
dropped two albums on courtesy half a
mill which is me and here boy we gonna
have at least one more for sure i don't
know when it's coming out but we already
you know what i mean it's locked in for
sure uh anything else you got that
you're working on any any sort of
anything else you wanna man just with my
new artist um shooting visuals from the
west side with left three you just put
out the [ __ ] on the beach which was dope
but mike yeah
kids deep dog mars kay franklin you know
what i mean check that out don't walk
away with quinn miller i'm gonna shoot
some of the solo videos now
um
and then 2022 i'll be on the road for
sure more new music you know i'm
flirting with the idea obviously i
dropped the t-fly information but just
man i want to stay consistent with the
music you know as long till i'm done
just with that part of my spirit you
know i'm saying that right now um
i really feel like not that i
rediscovered something but it feels like
you have though yeah i mean thank you
kev that's i didn't want to say like for
a minute it felt like you weren't really
like into this [ __ ] anymore yeah i mean
it was a lot of factors you know a
little bit what i touched on earlier
about the business side and just certain
things when things you know it
it gets like um
i don't want to say
not being into it because i was always
into writing songs and making music and
i do it by myself most of the time so
what is it not to be into but
um just rediscovering that passion you
know i'm saying in that initial mission
statement you know what i'm saying and
having great friends and people that you
know and love like here boy that to just
remind you you know i'm saying it and
support you through it and that's an
initially honestly why i thought it from
the west side would love three and why
was so important to me and just seeing a
a you know the
it's only been out like not even two
weeks so just seeing the initial you
know feedback just lets me know like
okay it is a lot on the table for us and
it is a segment of just music in general
and especially rap where it's like the
conversations and the things that i talk
about in the music that i talk about is
necessary you know i'm saying it's a
void and
i feel like it's my job to you know shed
some light on that no you're definitely
i feel like you've been back in your bag
the last couple years man thank you so
it's it's been great it's been great to
see um exactly i can't wait to hear the
t flash [ __ ] yeah nice it's gonna be
crazy it's gonna be dope man it's gonna
be on point like we got we already got
songs i'm excited about like sharing
that's why i feel you know real good
about the music that we're making and
even saying that it and just honestly
just us being it's really about when
as artists and friends that we all
seeing eye to eye and in a great space
as human beings you know i'm saying and
that's when i feel like and what i've
seen like you know not saying we all
gotta have a great a lot of money or you
know so far it's just you know just real
life and i feel like that's happening
right now and from the west side i would
love three i feel like it's definitely
one of the reasons why you know and i
want to continue that well look go get
the album that [ __ ] is fire thank you
man um i'm sure more visuals are coming
like you said yes so there'll be some
more visuals hopefully we'll be hitting
the road yeah 2022 i'm looking forward
to it probably like springtime we'll be
out there a lot of special guests fire
you know what i mean for sure there it
is man well look thanks for pulling up
man yes sir yes sir